there are a lot of things that are
created accidentally in evolution there
are a lot of side effects so you can
evolve a pleasure circuit for adaptive
things so they all eat food and drink
water and have sex and you can evolve
social cognition and then you can
connect up your social cognition center
with your pleasure center and then you
can take pleasure from positive social
evaluation which is something that you
could imagine would promote group
cohesion and in hunter-gatherer
societies would be adaptive but then
you've built a machine that can be
operated on in all kinds of ways in
terms of culture and behavior and we
shouldn't fall into the trap and think
that all those ways are adaptive are
useful just because they've evolved
evolution is a tinkerer not an engineer
as Francois Jacoby Amos Lee said and
when you're a tinkerer you throw things
together to solve the problem at hand
you don't build elegantly and you don't
build the way an engineer would build to
try to consider all the possible
contingencies you're just solving the
one problem that circumstances have
dealt you at this moment there's a
tendency particularly when looking at
brain function to be overawed by the
brain and well this is understandable we
say well human consciousness is manifest
in this two-and-a-half pounds of tissue
in our skull and now it's amazing you
say yeah that's amazing but that doesn't
mean that when you lift the hood and
look at how it's built either
anatomically or electrically or
genetically that what you see is well
engineered no it's a freaking mess in
there and it's a freaking mess both at
these biological levels and a lot of
times it's a freaking mess at the
behavior level we have two visual
systems in our brain a subconscious one
and a
Swan we have to auditory systems in our
brain a subconscious one and a conscious
one no engineer ever would have designed
it like this and then the information
from these two streams has to be fused
to create our behavior
it's a total Cluj it works pretty well
our brains are pretty impressive in what
they can do the engineering behind us is
completely insane it never is what
anyone would have designed given the
chance with all the time in the world on
a blank sheet of paper